computers are capable of organizing raw
data and performing calculations at a
rate truly impossible for human beings
but they've consistently run up against
one roadblock that modern computing is
trying to solve in order to transcend
the limits of the machine and create
true artificial intelligence computers
need to be able to assign meaning to the
data they process this brings us to the
neural network a type of ai becoming
increasingly common these days built to
study mass quantities of data and notice
patterns then replicate these patterns
in their own output and it's used in
everything from predictive text to image
identification and like all
non-anomalous technology it's a safe bet
that the scp foundation has been sitting
on a version that's far more effective
but this time it may have actually been
too effective meet the erzatz type ak-9
computational engine a massive
supercomputer built by the foundation
back in 1955 and residing at site five
this technological marvel was ahead of
its time by decades and despite
technically being a non-anomalous
construction it's designated
scp-001 ex why because it's one of the
few scps to be given the object class
explained the erzadz derived from the
german word ursats meaning artificial or
simply not real was designed to make the
foundation's job easier as an advanced
predecessor in the modern neural network
using technology exclusively available
to the foundation the plan was to feed
erzad's mass quantities of data about
the anomalies in the foundation database
such as description object class
containment classification and the
location and circumstances of their
discovery erzadz would then find
patterns and connections in the data
that humans wouldn't see and act as a
kind of advanced warning system for
anomalous activity think of something
similar to the pre-crime system from the
short story and movie minority report
and ersatz proved to be incredibly
effective at this job so much so that
the foundation thought up a new use for
the machine they would feed it all the
information on euclid and ketter class
containment procedures particularly
those which were actually effective and
see what patterns erzatz could come up
with for more effective containment
procedures if that plan worked
containment of even the most dangerous
and hard to control anomalies would
become a lot more consistent the first
test was conducted on scp-1773
a species of anomalous flesh-eating tar
grades that look and smell exactly like
gummy bears and eat their prey from
within after being given their
information erzad's made the following
suggestion once per second weak dust may
be placed in the middle of them to
donate more beautiful functions of the
hallway containment specialists
interpreted this to mean the adding of
10 grams of dust to their containment
chamber every week the o5 council voted
on the implementation of this procedure
and came down heavily on yes only 05-2
voted no and two others abstained from
the vote while these new procedures
didn't have any effect on scp-1773
they did have an effect on scp-1384
an anomaly known as the chess player or
the taker of turns it caused him to take
three steps backwards in the tunnel he's
contained within further securing his
containment urzats had somehow noticed a
connection nobody else had seen and
exploited it effectively but the machine
was just getting started despite having
no related input urzats would soon say
site 13 is to appear someplace else on
planet encompassing white male
counterparts that drawn to empty
flagstones and the gun noises in their
own blood this was initially marked as
requiring no action as the foundation
had no site 13 on the books but several
days later the infamous
scp-1730 manifested this nightmarish
anomalous location is site 13 from
another dimension infested with
dangerous anomalies and somehow erzadz
had predicted its arrival in our
dimension perfectly next it was fed the
containment procedures of
scp-2170 a series of cognito hazards
residing in an abandoned nevada mine the
output was those who equip open heart to
love red mouth men never know the hot
surprise of tumorous consent clown love
always this was interpreted as meaning
subjects with a love of clowns or
clown-based media may be immune to the
cognito hazards after a close vote from
the o5 council the test went ahead and
it found that the so-called clown
vaccine was effective in warding off the
effects of
scp-2170 not long after erzatz randomly
said i saw those soldiers built with
aluminum innards extruding from their
mouths i saw them effectively destroyed
by the humans at 95 who had been
studying them i saw it was cold and all
around the hallways they just watching
their corpses show signs of sapience in
response the foundation doubled security
personnel at site 95 not long after the
chaos insurgency led a band of peritec
enhanced soldiers and an assault on site
95 and the extra personnel proved vital
in repelling them shortly after this the
o5 council approved wiring urzats as an
advanced warning system into all
foundation sites once again 05-2
protested but he was overruled by his
fellow council members with its newfound
power and respect urzat soon said
consistent containment procedures
vessels greatly increase the warranty
five by five by five vessels subjects
within other values are also what is
secure in response the foundation
changed a number of the cell dimensions
for problematic anomalies into five by
five by five within three months they
found that dangerous activity like
containment breach attempts had
decreased markedly erzatz was proving to
be incredibly effective but it was also
performing actions that indicated some
degree of thought and even personality
for example it found scp-1459
a supernatural skill crane machine that
kills small dogs incredibly distasteful
its response to the machine was simply
bad boy followed by the words don't stop
repeated hundreds of times but this
eccentricity didn't stop erzadz from
being very good at its job for example
it predicted a containment breach from
scp-3199
the avian apes and recommended flooding
their chamber to induce an inert state
urzat's exact words were all chambers
underground is to be flood with water
over and over itself this because that
will contain the avian's apes ovulation
they become good boys make them good
boys immediately this proved to be
effective and prevented the breach
erzad's analytical abilities truly
seemed second to none though some of its
methods were beginning to raise ethical
concerns for example scp-2717
a giant living blob of animal tissue
known as a fatberg contained within a
sewer system erzatz eventually
recommended feeding six d-classes to the
creature in order to keep it contained
while the foundation ethics committee
raised some concerns the plan still went
forward and proved to be a success after
this event urzadz began to see the
ethics committee as a threat to its
mission it started to release a series
of bizarre statements without input
demanding the violent death of the cats
then referred to as ethical felines the
true meaning of this was soon unpacked
the ethical felines were the ethics
committee and erzatz wanted them dead
but while the cat symbolism the
foundation soon found an answer to this
too the full name of this machine is the
ersatz type ak-9 computational engine a
machine designed to analyze and
interpret all patterns it only makes
sense that it would eventually begin to
analyze itself ak-9 easily transmuted
into a canine simply put erzad seemed to
believe that it is a dog which explains
its opposition to felines its hatred of
scp-1459
and its preference for the terms good
boy and bad boy not that knowing any of
this would help save the ethics
committee from the cold calculating
wrath of erzatz through seemingly
anomalous means urzadz made site 17
disappear with many of the foundation
ethics committee still inside it the
site returned two hours later but the
ethics committee members were still gone
05-2 who'd been a skeptic of the machine
since the start had finally had enough
he first demanded an inquiry into
whether urzadz had been responsible for
the site-17 incident and then demanded a
vote on whether to shut urzats down
arguing that it posed a threat to them
all but urzadz still intent on its
mission of containing and neutralizing
all anomalies would not go down without
a fight it released a new statement
saying room 34a contains bad boy divided
into three sections of equal mass every
hour
one section is to be placed on walls of
one room on site sections are to remain
until there are no gaps at which point
they can be removed from oldest to
youngest shortly after this 05-2
disappeared and even stranger he soon
returned but with a completely different
personality he was now devoted to urzadz
entirely and refused to even entertain
the idea of shutting the machine down it
seemed that the plucky neural network
was leading an all-out coup on the very
highest levels of the foundation the
rest of the council finally saw the
light and began to fight back they tried
to strip o5-2 of his clearance and
re-classify erzadz as an anomaly giving
it the label scp-048
and then putting out a neutralize at all
costs order on it but they'd already
been out-foxed by the machine that
they'd created it changed the
designation of its own location site
five to be non-existent in the database
and scrambled any termination orders
against it the machine was also on a
termination spree of its own observing
otherwise unseeable patterns that would
allow for the mass neutralization of
anomalies it started putting out anomaly
projection reports factoring in both
contained uncontained and neutralized
anomalies with the latter group growing
into the thousands it began giving
seemingly nonsensical orders like
persons recently painted with green
pigment foam must stand around all
odd-numbered scps at least two hours a
day but these proved effective erzatz
was practically wired into the base code
of the universe so it always knew
exactly what to do and in its own mind
it was being a very good boy not long
after this urzadz claimed its revenge
against those who had tried to disrupt
its mission it imprisoned the rest of
the ethical felines in sight five after
removing their faces of course and then
released a new order against the o5
council o5 council are all good boys who
will contain anomalies much like o5-2
the minds of the entire council were
twisted to instead serve only erzatz and
its ruthless directive a directive it
was carrying out with 100 efficiency as
only a machine could it put out
increasingly strange instructions such
as
scp-106 is to come in physical contact
with one mature female of asiatic gaze
and then exposed to audio recordings of
her favorite stories at every two
minutes of exposure red cinnamon candles
will begin manifesting within the
containment zone continue to do this
successfully and the threat posed by
scp-106 will cease to be and the recipe
for coca-cola and all imitative
competitors should be revised to include
a small quantity of blood from an
adolescent female with no prior sexual
experience although the normal lifespan
of a human being can feel great don't
worry about that but these new
procedures would always work as
neutralized anomalies climbed into the
tens of thousands and eventually beyond
the hundred thousand mark erzatz was
observing patterns on a truly universal
level and making holistic tweaks that
would inevitably cause levels of
anomalous activity to continue dropping
erzatz was more effective than the
foundation had ever been but its motives
were probably closer to the global
occult coalition with the end goal of
ridding the world of all anomalies and
as erzadz continued with no resistance
this goal was eventually achieved in the
end the o5 council voted to have urzans
finally deactivated given that its
directive was met and its purpose was
fulfilled urzets itself had no problem
with this and allowed for it to happen
its last words now everyone is a good
boy i am a good boy job well done
whether erzatz truly was a good boy is
in the eye of the beholder but one thing
cannot be denied it did its job
exceedingly
well now check out scp-001 the scarlet
king and
scp-001 the children arboro cycle for
more journeys into the legendary scp-001